Becky Lynch welcome to the show good
talk to you again good to talk to you
you guys for having me in studio of
course I'm glad you're in studio you've
been on like I've seen you multiple
times in the last like two weeks because
you've been on this media run that's
like non-stop you just can't get enough
of the champ no one can get enough of a
champ
well Becky Lynch is of course defending
the SmackDown Women's Championship at
evolution on Sunday you're so
bright-eyed and bushy-tailed how long
have you have you just been on a media
run for like forever I've been enjoying
the hell out of this yes this is what
I've asked for right is what I wanted
right is what I've said I've been
overlooked I never get the immediate
Piron tsa's and the champ wants to talk
the chap needs to get her voice out
there right yes that's what I'm getting
to do so I'm very grateful for it good
but you say with such intensity like yes
there's no like sort of it's not a warm
gratefulness it's an angry gratefulness
exactly yeah cuz the champ had to
scratch and claw to get there right and
everybody's loving it right everybody's
loving it right so I'm like I told you
so you did everybody's I never here we
are do you feel like you know I think
people would make a comparison to Conor
McGregor do you watch Connor sell fights
and go like this is this is the way to
sell a fight he runs his mouth running
his mouth yeah that's where I'm getting
ya Primus honestly I think it's it's an
Irish thing it's an Irish it against at
the gap it is yeah it is and I have a
gift you do and I have any of the gap
yes
well Becky I mean did you I know you
thought you would be here in the sense
that like you start becoming a
professional wrestler to one day be the
champion but before we've talked about
this before but before you were a
professional wrestler you did every job
imaginable Under the Sun yeah that's
that's that's been crazy but coming back
to New York you know because there's
been so many pockets of my life that
have been in this city you know so the
first time I ever came to America was to
New York City 7 years old my mom took me
over for Christmas she was a flight
attendant best Christmas of my life and
still to date I would say and it was
just it was just so magical and then I
was a flight attendant myself followed
mom's foots that I did my mom can you
hook me up with her with a gig here so
she she was retired
I just retired from wrestling at the
tender age of 19 I didn't know what it
was gonna do with myself and she was
handing in her resignation she was like
well I hand in your resume I was like
yeah sure you might as well and then lo
and behold here I was and we would stay
just up the road I'm in the Sheraton
there right in Times Square huh
and yeah so it's crazy and then I was
working in a bar on 50th between 9th and
10th called Hibernia when I was in
between my first and second year of
college so just so much of my life as
rotater in the city were you in the bar
bartending bartending and the bouncing
was not fancy
I was not bouncing but if anybody got
out of hand when do you retire from
being a flight attendant like how do you
know it's time because that seems like a
job you could kind of do forever yeah I
mean if you're into that sort of thing
right and I didn't love it so I was
there for two and a half years I wanted
to do different things with my life but
the job is so all-encompassing like with
WWE you're gone all the time your
schedule is so demanding and it was hard
for me to take up any other hobbies and
and and having been so dedicated to
something like wrestling before that I
knew what it was like to have a passion
and at that time I didn't have it for
anything and I needed it you know no I
wanted to try and find it and that's why
I left time College yeah and that's why
you started doing all kinds of jobs just
to feel like something's got a spark
here absolutely right absolutely and I
felt like and it's crazy because I've
kept journals my whole life right and I
I remember writing down that I just want
to I just want to make a mistake I just
want to have a big giant Messel just so
that I can feel like I'm doing something
like I'm alive because I felt like I was
doing everything to the to the letter
into the tea and by the book and it just
was so on fulfilling and interesting
it's like one like solid line the whole
time like there's no back against the
wall there's no real reason to do
anything it's just existing absolutely
exactly and just felt so flat
like I was flatlining and and that's why
I need to get out of here I need to do
something that sets my soul on fire life
the way wrastling did and lo and behold
here
but it is is it's crazy because I guess
that's how the Becky Lynch character
felt right she was doing everything
right everything by the book and just
existing in WWE and it's time to take a
risk and make a big heel turn and and
screw the audience screw everybody it's
my time absolutely right heel turn I
don't know what what you mean by that I
think I just went from a non-believer to
a believer right exactly
that's why I love it now why did you
quit at 19 so okay
long story ma'am long story but let's
make it a short sue yeah and so at the
time I became obsessed with getting into
the WWE right and as a teenager but at
the time they they didn't want girls
that look like me or so I was told and
and not by any reliable source right and
another fellow independent rest just
another guy who also couldn't get in
yeah it was like now they don't want you
they don't want you they don't want
girls like you is exactly what they said
and so I was like well I'll make them
want girls like me right so then we said
party building and I got emaciated right
and I did it all wrong
and at that time then I wasn't I wasn't
I wasn't training as much in the ring I
was just concentrating on eating my
freakin four inches of chicken or
whatever it was and and and with that I
just every bump I took just we got more
and more painful said nothing to protect
me and I know getting built like you
never wrestling body yeah you have a
wrestling body and I was skinny and had
nothing to protect me and then I was my
visa ran out in Canada it was just a
perfect storm of just things not working
out and I was back home in Ireland and
my mom was like what's your plan what's
your plan what's your plan with your
plan and there's no plan with with
wrestling you don't know when when the
call is gonna happen and when you're
sitting at home you're not earning money
and my mom just wanted me to get my life
together and took what's your plan I'm
like well I'm trying this thing and then
anyway I got hurt and in a match in
Germany them and I came
wearing sunglasses I was all busted open
like freaking hanging out the side of my
head she what the hell are you doing
wearing sunglasses indoors like I'm a
rock star
[Laughter]
how did you get mom
what was it that damaged your face too
that suplex a girl onto my head so in a
moment of aggression what happened was
that the crowd started chanting women's
wrestling and it wasn't in the sense
that they chant it now it was in a
derogatory sense yeah terrible right
it's like well I'll show you and as it
turns out it was pretty terrible yeah it
was awful so I suplex her she held on to
makes you scared obviously and and she
landed on my face so hurt I just lands
on your eye socket yeah yeah my eyes
just boss open I get up the top just
blow it all I can see is right and and
yeah so anyway so I come back my moms
like we please give hopefully please
give up I'm like up always what you want
to hear from a good parent yeah just
just come on like what are you doing
with your life yeah so I'm like I'm
trying to move with a plan B so at the
time I was like okay well let me go to
Orlando let me do a personal training
course and then at least I have a plan B
and anytime you do Plan B it always
becomes plan a right you take your focus
off the price and that's what happened I
and rope in Orlando not realized and you
need a car to get around and things like
that or money right family you need
money
as yeah as a person we need money to get
where our yeah and you also need money
to put in the car so you drive places
and there's money absolutely right
and to eat and things like that right
you know exist
so anyway end up in Orlando and and I
don't know what to do with myself I've
become very lost to become very
depressed and very confused and I'm 19
I'm at my own and I didn't have a
support system I didn't have it and I
just shied away from wrestling I
couldn't because it had betrayed the
world yes you're dreaming and it didn't
work out and you were like well this
thing used to be so good to me and now
it makes me feel so bad well I don't
know that I ever felt that about
wrestling but I certainly felt that
about myself
I see and I've certainly felt ill and
even committed to delivery my goodness
how many times did I say W right there
when the Irish Irish captain I here with
Sheamus to I'm like I don't know what if
he pronounces every syllable of that
word but you get the gist yes yeah so
anyway so even when we came in WWE and
in NXT like I felt just this tremendous
amount guilt because I felt like and I
remember meeting Sami Zayn and Sami Zayn
was on one of my last tours and he had
had been wrestling the entire time
pursuing his dream and there I was who
had given it up for seven years and I
was in the same spot I felt like fraud I
felt like I don't deserve to be here i
right turn my back on on my passion and
what I loved and on this business
because I couldn't face it I had some
demons to face and so I felt like I
shouldn't have been there like I felt
like I I had to pay penance and I did
that too just too much of an extent you
know for yeah the first long while that
I was in WWE how long did it take for
you to shake that off
oh I least a year but I think it's been
ongoing and and certainly yeah certainly
if the first few years total err yeah it
was there just that guilt that I had
this passion I had this dream and I gave
up on and all these other people have
been sitting here paying their dues the
whole time and I I walked away and now I
get the same opportunity absolutely
so did you start working like how do you
handle it right - I have right now you
start working like twice as hard as
everybody else do you oh yeah yeah
absolutely and but here's the other
thing is I think then having what the
great thing about it is if I didn't walk
away and this is what would happen was I
realized where I was was the perfect
time with the perfect time the comb up
and it was something special you feel if
I hadn't walked away I wouldn't have
been there at that exact moment and then
I wouldn't have been with Sasha and
Bailey and Charlotte right he wouldn't
have been the four horsewomen you know
and
and so it all felt very serendipitous
but it allowed me to be so unbelievably
grateful and and and I would sit in my
apartment and sometimes I would cry yes
the champ cried and that was before she
was the chance that was before she was
the child right thank you cried the
chance doesn't the child unless she's
something really moving like a
three-legged poop yeah and just made the
fact that that that wrestling was
affording me the groceries in my fridge
and I the roof over my head that money
that we were talking about before money
you're actually getting some that it
eluded me before the last time I was in
Orlando's right I had it was paid by
something but I love to do and what was
better in Orlando being there with no
money or with my with any money was
better okay shocking me enough I'm
writing that down cuz I'm trying to
figure out New York right now and so far
I only know without money so I'm gonna
try to do it with money crying oh yeah
cuz it's better it's it's so much fun
that's great yeah now did you ever get
to a point when you weren't before you
got to W before you got back into
wrestling did you get to a point where
you actually did feel like everything
had gone away like you were saying
before everything was by the book you
were flatlining like did you get to a
place where you were like my backs
against the wall I have absolutely
nothing this is what I asked for in the
worst way type of thing Oh probably a
few times I remember showing up in New
York in between my first and second to
your college and I was like I probably
won't even have to work for the whole
summer I have so much money in my bank
account
one thousand dollars right so you were
never numbers person Becky Lynch has
some skills math is not so I arrived in
New York thousand dollars rich right
after day one six hundred dollars gone I
was like oh my goodness
I might need to get a job that's when I
wandered into Hibernia like you got any
jobs I had so I had a I I didn't even
know anybody over here I had a hostel
booked at an Olympic circle uh-huh for
three nights probably really nice room
with three strangers bunk bed right bunk
beds well that's on c-types
that's where they yeah that's sort of
young girl with $1,000 to her name
coming to New York with no friends wants
to just go to a hostel and share a room
with three strangers I like to go wrong
exactly
so what else did you do cuz didn't you
go to like did you go to stunt school or
circus school or sometimes I was I went
to I studied the art of clown that's
right I studied the art of clam I don't
want to trivialize it wasn't the way I
phrased my question yes so you studied
the art of clown yes I see yeah like
there was an expression on your face
that I didn't appreciate there I don't
mean to look down on the art of clown
it's quite an art I'm sure I've never
done it I'm sure I'm not capable of
doing it it well everybody's capable you
think so yeah well you just need to put
a lot of dedication like the champ did
right um I did my thesis on on the art
of clown and how it leads to a truthful
performance do you think that that's
true
absolutely my conclusion is that it's
all make-believe right right and so
little kids play make-believe and they
go in and they play doctors or whatever
and they really believe their doctor and
clowning is just clowning around right
and making believe so what the hell are
we doing with this acting degree can you
just play right basically right now
after three years doing my degree I
concluded let's just play make-believe
but when you're I mean I feel like
watching wrestling for all my life has
changed the way that I look at
everything like when I'm watching the
news I'm like yeah but it's all like I
don't want to look at wrestling and go
like yeah but they all they all know
what's going on literally everything I
watch I go yeah they don't know
and they know what's going on like this
is all they're all everybody's playing
their roles here absolutely right
completely and I feel like it gives you
a different view on life that I think
it's more correct than most other people
who take everything so seriously
possibly yeah 100% and do you watch
movies in that way too
like I look at that like a big baby
things okay the heat right now yeah oh
look a homespun right it's that
three-act structure yes it never fails
yeah here's the falsies you know yeah
exactly did you were you looking at
stuff like that when you weren't
wrestling like is that how you knew
that's really where I need to get back
to I don't know that I was but I also
don't know that I only stood the
structure as much as I do now and but
but I always just felt like I don't
finish business and I was wrote that I
had unfinished business and it would
always pop up in my head and finn bálor
can test this because i would always sit
down with him eyes I'm gonna go back to
rest no I'm not I'm doing this other
thing and I love this of it but I'm
gonna go back to wrestling tomorrow and
you know like so I constantly changed my
mind a flip-flop and one time we were
sitting down having lunch in Dublin and
he was off in Japan or whatever he'd
come back and I was like well you know I
keep thinking that I'm supposed to do
this thing but and he just just go back
now yeah because I'm not sitting here
with you in another 10 years and you're
gonna be wishing that you'd gone back
then but it's gonna be too late
I made it tell you my back did you think
at any point you were gonna be a clown
and no possibly not no I don't think
that I was gonna actually work as a
clown right but I just appreciated the
art I see so you really just took it to
give you a foundation a foundation yes
right yeah a helpful foundation so many
actors have used the art of the art of
clen yeah
now when you were going to school for
the art of clown were there other people
there that were like no this is what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna go be a clown yeah
yeah yeah where do people work if
they're I guess Ringling Brothers and
stuff like that yeah yeah because I feel
like there's even less gigs for clowns
than there are for wrestlers
there are solo theater performances oh
these PI own troops yeah but do people
like pay a ticket to see just like a
solo clown oh yeah really
yeah yeah is that like French Berlin
fringe theatre exactly yeah yeah like in
New York if some guy was like yeah I do
a clown show I'm like there's like
everything's going on here why would I
go to a see some guy just do the art of
clown by himself why wouldn't you I
guess I don't know enough about it okay
well there I go that's why you might
want to seek it out that's my ignorance
speaking yes is what it is yeah yeah do
I have a thesis that I wrote about it I
love coffee I'd love to read it sometime
I feel like I'd really start to develop
an appreciation for it I think you would
did you save it like the way you said
you do you save all your journals I save
all my journal did you shave your clown
thesis I saw I believe that yeah no it's
got to be at home somewhere but I
remember I didn't proofread it and then
when I got it back
I like opened up the first page nothing
but spelling mistakes is a gosh darn it
yeah no wonder I didn't get a first
class on his own got a second class on
us because the content was clearly great
right it was there yeah right so the
champs a genius exactly except with
spelling in numbers yes right things but
those are the details and that's not as
important yeah I did a I had to do a
thesis about Disney movies when I was in
college you know and I did it about the
the racial stereotypes that exist in
these Disney movies okay and I wrote
this whole thesis there's like 20 pages
the whole thing and I got an email back
in the middle of summer saying Sam I
want to give you a grade but there's not
one citation in this entire paper
nothing is cited here there's nothing
this isn't a research paper like you
just made stuff up about Disney for 20
pages theory right I just started
writing oh and went for 20 pages and
handed it in and they were like there's
no citations here this isn't a research
paper and I was like oh no I forgot to
put in the citations just and I went on
my computer and found the paper and I
was like oh my god oh my god and she
started adding citations to things and I
did I did great on it you but you had
doing the research you just forgot to
research I mean I see stuff tobacco what
you were saying I'd seen the movies okay
I knew the books where the research was
in okay so you just cited those books
where you know what it's in there
something like you know what's in there
yeah so that's what I cited okay but
didn't did you have to quote things I
mean what is she gonna look through the
books and find the page
unlike you think yeah like let's get to
the end let's get to the the root of
this this is a lesson for college kids
everywhere yeah yes it's it's the the
path of least resistance is a path that
I've always believed in exactly right
and you know if she's willing to email
me and say hey there's no citations in
this and not just give me an F she's
probably willing to be like hey I don't
think your page numbers are right and
I'd go oh let me correct him and I'd
figure out whatever the next thing was
does anybody do that when they're
looking at so do they go oh oh well this
is an interesting theory on page 126 of
this book whatever let me go to the
library take it right no way I mean your
professor you've already got a read like
about 15 20 of these giant papers the
last thing you want to do is look up all
these quotes and who would be brazen
enough to just quote a book that he just
saw the title of the book who would do
that but you yes yes yes I did yes know
that I'm thinking about it more people
probably should be they should because
he was gonna go to that effort right
exactly exactly
it's like you know I would do the same
thing when they would ask you I went to
film school and they would ask you like
a question about a film that I didn't
bother going to see but clearly in the
question it was either like how did the
local people react when this film was
made about their culture it's all it's
one of two things how did they react I
don't know oh I had but I don't know
it's either okay
they reacted well because it was
authentic yeah or they didn't react well
because it was inauthentic okay so how
do you know whether it's gonna be
authentic or not when you haven't seen
the movie you have to pick one okay and
then either either get a hundred percent
or go down in a blaze of glory just
commit just either be zero zero or
absolutely 100 cuz if you're wishy-washy
then they're gonna know you got a 50-50
shot at being right and then they're
like I clearly saw the movie or he just
made all this up so how often would you
be would you be right more often than
not like I was better than 50/50 okay
you could usually figure out in the
question which direction they were going
yeah you know yeah and the net that
that's all you need to do I like your
style yeah it but it kind of reminds me
that you have that option for air you
know when you don't understand what
somebody saying to you and there and you
ask them to repeat it you
and they say whatever what times or
whatever you like an eventually you've
asked them so many times what they're
saying yeah you just go yeah five yeah
absolutely yeah absolutely so like
you're in that area
like I would do that yeah yeah but I
wouldn't I do it like after the first
one okay I wouldn't bother going like
could you repeat that cuz I'm like let's
let's move on to the next thing
look we don't need to just dwell in this
I don't understand what you're asking
you know what I mean
totally like you'd be like what time is
it and be like yeah okay so see you
later and you know Oh cause it's time
for you to leave time to go yes right
and you get that you think that's a pond
I like that yeah I mean it's not a pun
I mean metaphorically okay yeah
metaphorically it is so evolution is on
Sunday sound Sunday in Long Island in
long I might yeah so anybody who's local
should be going to this show if you
don't already have tickets cuz this is
historic you got a last woman standing
match yeah which I would imagine is
gonna be sheer brutality yep and there's
I mean you wouldn't for her well yeah I
mean you're gonna unleash sheer
brutality yeah you couldn't you know
with a straight face go and tell all
these people how great you are if you
weren't planning on just unleashing hell
on Charlotte at this show on Sunday
absolutely now are you more focused on
your match and the performance or are
you more focused on the historic
implications of having a giant match on
the first all-women's WWE pay-per-view
my match of my performance that's what
it is absolutely right because solid
bait cement on my lazy and and showing
everybody why I'm the greatest time for
all time now I see on Twitter
you've been talking crap to like
everybody yeah on the roster yep like
and and I think it's interesting because
in wrestling on Twitter sometimes it's
not like that much wrestling like it's
people just kind of being oh today I
went grocery shopping and this is
bah-bah-bah and this is and you I might
as well be watching Smackdown you're
like yeah but you're not the champ so
who cares if you want grocery shopping
absolutely right the champ doesn't care
if it's you groceries right yeah now how
do your co-workers react when you see
them and they're like when you have to
why
to talk [ __ ] on Twitter I don't know I'm
just trying to live my life and you're
still harassing me at home on Twitter
why are you doing that the chump doesn't
care doesn't care doesn't care no care
about their feelings
this is business right I'm here for
business right and I'm gonna make
business right yeah you're not there to
make friends no I'm not there to make
friends I tried that right didn't work
out so well for me no no so now what I'm
gonna do is pick them all off one by one
and I don't care how long it takes me
but the champ realized that in the space
of maybe one year at the beginning what
like seven people turned on me right or
attacked me that seems like the problem
is more you than them at sapling and
that's what the team's like but it was
never it was never wave as well the only
the only thing that was my problem was
that they took advantage of my good
nature exactly I was too good-natured
you know what they did they miss mistook
your kindness for weakness ha what a
mistake they made right when they're
gonna pay for it well now they're
feeling it on Twitter every day
absolutely and that's that's what that's
so so legacy I've already got that right
we all know that the champ is the
greatest of all time actually that's
done that's all I meant
yeah so you know in just a couple years
you went from oh my god I don't know if
I deserve to be here - hey good news my
legacy has been cemented belief right
right and this is what I aim to do yes
exactly it's a secret if you were at
that book oh yeah right wonderful you
think about a light switch and there's a
light switch you you think but how does
light come on I don't know how it
happens but I turn the light and there
it is it's like that insane clown posse
song when they pose the question magnets
how do they work and they surmise it's a
miracle it's a miracle right yeah so uh
have you have you watched it there it is
a DVD about it about magnets know the
secret oh yeah I've seen absolutely
incredible right but I've also seen the
Insane Clown Posse's music video for the
magnets
it was wonderful amazing okay amazing
yeah yeah yeah the secret one of my one
of my favorite books of all time well
yeah it makes people really paranoid
about their thoughts right because oh my
god this isn't what I should be thinking
yeah though they start to lose me when
they start saying things like if you
want to lose weight all you have to do
is think thin thought
and I'm like I think there is a diet and
exercise regimen that goes into it as
well no you just think well you're a
better shape than me so you would know
well you know I just think right you got
McDonald's you're like yeah I mean the
Big Mac but I'm thinking thinking about
how thin I am yeah and then you're great
yeah oh I see I always see the models
and they eat whatever they want right so
they're probably just thinking really
skinny thought it's the C so I do the
same but there was a moment in that when
they were like it's like when you turn
on a light switch and light comes on I
don't know how it works I'm like yes but
I like just because you don't know the
explanation doesn't mean there isn't
it's the wires that are behind the
switch that are actually connected to
those little light ball was the pop-up
it's not pretty actually it's technology
that was developed centuries centuries
ago yeah but you know thoughts as well
now you are on my wrestling podcast this
week as well yes and you said your quote
I believe was I asked you about Ronda
Rousey yes and you said that you did
want to fight Ronda Rousey because she
was like a slot machine in the sense
that you the more you kicked her the
more money came out yes the harder I
kick her them the harder you kick the
more money comes yes um you still feel
this way you have any second thoughts
where you're like Ronda Rousey is a
beast I don't know if I want to be on a
public forum saying I want to kick her
until money falls out of her absolutely
not absolutely not because you're the
champ I'm the champ but sure she she is
also the champ right yes but I've been
in this business a lot longer than she
has right yes and I've proved myself in
this business right she is not so you're
ready yet to I mean she's a champ right
is yet to she have to go against the
likes of me are you surprised at how how
good she's gotten so quickly the
progress that she's made in unbelievable
right unbelievable she is a natural yeah
you know who wasn't a natural who was
not an Emmy right you know what hard
work beats talent every time I always
say that she's not a hard worker but but
she's talented she's talented right I'm
just a hard worker
I'm the same way her torn up I was born
with very few talents but somehow I'm
here and here your cuz I just stuck
around you know I just kept going
absolutely and you wrote a hell of a
thesis right I wrote a great
you wrote a great thesis but you would
like you would like a one-on-one
opportunity with Rhonda reps of course
right right and what type of stage would
you like this on I wouldn't mind a
Wrestlemania you in mind I wouldn't mind
the WrestleMania you'd accept that I
would accept the WrestleMania right do
you think that you would be victorious
of course right of course right there's
nothing like there's no doubts in my
mind anymore that's the thing Sam
Roberts right there was there too before
but nothing no there's no doubts good
for you we we have I thought we
established this no we did I just wanted
to test you okay all right yeah and
there was no guessing no this was sight
8sy taters it's sighted may be generally
citation yeah see on there my journal
we'll listen of 84